[Musik]
er ist die regierende supermacht der
mode in unserer branche sieht jeder
ralph lauren als vorbild an ein traum
fabrikant der milliarden verdiente indem
er sich vorstellte was andere sich
wünschten jedes mal wenn ich kleidung
mache ich
glaube seit walt disney war niemand so
erfolgreich darin millionen und
abermillionen von menschen für seine
fantasien zu begeistern
ralph lauren strahlt eine aura des
gehobenen lebenshaus als marke steht für
klassische zeitlose
die marke ist ihre erinnerung an diesen
fabelhaften lebensstil aber sein leben
war nicht so perfekt ich glaube er
dachte das wäre das letzte mal dass er
den falschen weg eingeschlagen hat das
war es aber nicht bei weitem wir haben
immer gescherzt dass er immer den plan
hatte die welt zu übernehmen er hat die
welt übernommen daran besteht kein
zweifel
[Musik]
ralph lauren ist die berühmteste ein
mann marke des planeten eine marke die
synonym für einen überlegenen lebensstil
ist wusste immer dass er nicht gewinnen
würde wenn er keine risiken eingeht und
er geht immer an die grenzen erhält sich
nachts wach er hat angst er könnte
versagen er ist besessen brillanz
unberechenbar und schwierig aber er kann
auch nett und interessant und süß sein
er ist ein bündel von widersprüchen
lohan besteht darauf dass die bilder von
ihm seine geschichte erzählen und wollte
nicht an unserem programm teilnehmen
bevor er ralph lauren war war er war /
schätzt das jüngste von vier kindern
dass die kleider des bruders auftrug
1939 als sohn jüdischer einwanderer aus
der arbeiterklasse geboren wuchs er in
der sein vater war amateur künstler mehr
wenn man mit jemandem zusammenlebt für
den ästhetik wichtig ist hat das
auswirkungen auf das kind in diesem
haushalt
von original aufwändig das wirkliche
leben von
waging soja shiva und trug eine kippa
und alle anderen utensilien orthodoxer
juden jeden tag
er erzählte mir dass er ganz am anfang
als er in der bronx lebte ins kino ging
und sich buchstäblich in die fantasien
der filme dieser ära stürzte die
wirklich eine der großen kino epochen
der späten 40er und frühen 50er jahre
war
warum hältst ding ist eine jugendfreie
wir alle haben als kinder auf die
kinoleinwände geguckt und auf die
schauspieler wie gut sie aussahen preis
machte vor allem fred astaire
und er hat sich wirklich in die szenen
hinein versetzt in denen männer wie gary
cooper und cary grant spielten er sieht
die figuren die seine träume und seine
visionen bevölkern und diese vision
diese fähigkeit in eine fantasiewelt
einzutauchen hat rolf in die modebranche
mitgebracht
in einem der beiden einzigen großen
fernseh interviews die er je gegeben hat
erzählte loren 1993 charlie rose von den
auswirkungen dieser erfahrung
ich wurde sehr von filmen beeinflusst
von einer welt die einen sinn für träume
hatte einen sinn für etwas anderes
und was mich an diesen roten
beeinflusste war der good guy der cowboy
nicht der kitschige kehrt aber wenn man
auf dem weißen pferd
mein gefühl war ich hatte eine
integrität an die ich glaubte vielleicht
hat es wirklich
aber ich hatte einen standpunkt ich war
sehr stark
warum hetzt ihn erzählt dass lauren hält
den vater einen schneider als teenager
darum bat ihm einen seiner ersten anzüge
zu machen ich erinnere mich dass ich mit
ihm zu meinem vater ging und es sehr
schwierig war ich sagte zu meinem vater
papa ach was er will er sagte ich kann
es ihm nicht recht machen ich sagte okay
das war's auch wenn er ein perfektionist
war laurin war ein mann für alle fälle
er mochte basketball am liebsten würde
ich sagen alles gut wie geht es ihnen
als opfer winfrey ihn auf seiner ranch
in colorado interview erzählte laurin
von seinen frühesten ambitionen wollten
sie schon immer ein cowboy sein wollte
baseballspieler werden ich wollte
schauspieler werden wollte tänzer werden
eigentlich wollte batman werden dass das
geheimnis dass ich im verraten da
draußen
als teenager entschieden er und sein
bruder jerry sich für eine
namensänderung darf sagte zu mir das
problem mit dem namen widgets ist dass
er das wort enthält und er musste
endlose hänseleien über sich ergehen
lassen die sich durch die ganze
schulzeit zogen und auch in der armee
rolf schlug mir vor dass der name laurin
von lauren bacall kommt die eine große
stilikone und schauspielerin war
abends besuchte er wirtschaft einen
abschluss gemacht 1964 nach einem kurzen
abstecher in die armee heiratete der 26
jährige lauren
praxis kennen gelernt hatte er heiratete
das mädchen das im cabrio perfekt außer
mit ihren blonden haaren wurde sein
model seinen rückhalt ricky war glaube
ich immer in seinem hinterkopf
immer noch auf der suche nach seinem
platz in der welt wandte sich lauren der
new yorker mode branche zu er wurde
verkäufer bei brooke crothers und dann
bei einer reihe von krawatten
herstellern
ich nahm ihn zu seinem ersten ko spiel
in bleiburg mit wo wir all diese
fabelhaften dinge sahen
über leder werde die großen schlanken
blondinen großen hüther
einfach eine high society von der wir
nichts was
diese fabelhafte welt verwandelte lorenz
vision er rief mich an und sagte er
wolle sich selbstständig machen und was
ich von dem namen halten würde er sagte
er denkt an players polo und ich sagte
ralf hohl ist elitär
kaum jemand weiß etwas darüber aber
jeder spielt also hast du keine wahl es
muss players sein sagte ok vielen dank
und der rest ist geschichte
es war die ära der einfarbigen schmalen
krawatten als lauren etwas radikales vor
schluss klappt bunte breite krawatten
er machte sich selbstständig eine seiner
ersten stationen bloomingdale's marvin
tram war damals ceo und präsident von
bloomingdale's kurz vor seinem tod
sprach er über den forschen jungen
designer
er zeigte sie dem krawatten einkäufer
von bloomingdale's der sagte gefallen
mir die kaufe aber
ich will nicht dass ralph lauren label
drauf haben ich will ein blumen- und
das macht er darum kämpfte ein auftrag
von blumenthal zu bekommen er machte den
koffer zu und sagte ohne meinen namen
will ich den auftrag nicht
[Musik]
einige monate nachdem ralph lauren das
angebot von bloomingdale's ausgeschlagen
hatte rief ihn das renommierte
unternehmen zurück ich fand die
krawatten großartig und wenn er seinen
namen drauf haben wollte war das okay
ich war sicher dass sich die krawatten
verkaufen würden und das taten sie auch
andere bekannte namen in der herren
bekleidungsbranche wollten auch
mitmachen stewart und nehmen markus
innerhalb eines jahres verkaufte laurin
krawatten für eine halbe million dollar
und er hatte noch größeres vor
seine marke zu erweitern er wollte das
tun indem er sich kleidung vorstellte
die er selbst tragen würde
du dachtest du kannst in england kaufen
was cary grant ruck ist fred astaire
trug aber du konntest nicht in ein
geschäft gehen und es kaufen als ich kam
war das geschäft überhaupt nicht so die
sachen die ich macht und über nicht
kaufen man konnte sie nicht finden
bloomingdales sah das potenzial und den
profit in lawrence linie wir arbeiteten
eng zusammen von krawatten über
herrenhemden bis hin zu anzügen
sportjacken rosen die ganze kollektion
und dann kam und sagte marin ich will
eine damenkollektion machen
der wichtigste durchbruch für ralph
lauren war wahrscheinlich dass er eine
eigene boutique bei bloomingdale's bekam
das war der moment wo jemand außerhalb
seiner phantasiewelt ihn zustürmte und
ihn in die geschäftswelt einführte
es war das erste mal dass bloomingdale's
einem designer eine eigene boutique im
geschäft gehabt
und das geschäft wuchs sehr schnell ich
wusste genau was er im laden wollte was
er auf den etagen wollte und was er an
den wänden wollte es entstand ein
richtiges ralph lauren umfeld
wenn man sich die 60er und 70er jahre
ansieht da wurde kleidung auf
schaufensterpuppen gepackt sie haben die
geschichten erzählt rolf nahm dich in
eine fantasiewelt mit auf eine insel in
die hamptons in den wilden westen
drei jahre nach dem verkauf seiner
ersten krawatten gewann lauren 1970 den
oscar der modebranche den codie award
für seine menswear linie und 1979 kaufte
lorenz das erste von vielen luxusautos
der pulitzer-preis architektur und
design kritiker paul goldberger hat über
rolf lorenz berühmte autosammlung
berichtet ich glaube es war ein mercedes
cabrio dass er sich zu diesem zeitpunkt
nicht ganz leisten konnte er kaufte es
trotzdem weil er genau diese art von
aufstreben verstand die er anderen
leuten zu verkaufen versuchte
er griff auch seine frühere fantasie
zurück das polospiel und führte sein
logo ein den polo spieler aber trotz des
starken umsatzes geriet das unternehmen
in finanzielle schwierigkeiten
laurin war gezwungen den größten teil
seiner persönlichen ersparnisse zu
investieren 100000 dollar er stellte
auch einen neuen geschäftspartner ein
den einzelhandels manager peter strohm
der einsprang und zehn prozent des
unternehmens für 6000 dollar kaufte ich
glaube er war sehr besorgt sie lieferten
alles zu spät der vertriebs muster war
völlig falsch
wir lösten diese probleme
brachten die richtigen leben dazu die
richtige menge zu kaufen und alles
richtig zu präsentieren
zwei jahre später wieder auf dem
richtigen weg bekam lorenz marke einen
aufschwung hat seine männer kleidung im
großen gatsby mit spielte seine
fähigkeit kleider zu entwerfen die wie
kostüme aussagen die wie kleider
aussagen die die kostüme haus sahen war
unvergleichlich
aber ich glaube dass der claim den er
entwarf annie hall wichtiger war der
annie hall look inspirierte eine der
ersten damen kollektion
und der designer selbst war auf das
haupt model in den werbekampagnen seiner
marke
hat auf vielen seiner modenschau
fotografiert er
trägt diese sachen als es der zur
verkörperung dessen was er kreiert
mit seinen jüngern wissen sie ralf in
seinen kleidern das war authentisch
das unternehmen brachte eine reihe neuer
kollektionen heraus darunter auch eine
umfangreiche haushalts kollektion laurin
lizenzierte seinen namen auch für andere
produkte und tauschte damit kontrolle
gegen kapital ein
1986 ging ralph lauren aufs ganze und
gab 30 millionen dollar aus um einen
eigenständigen flagship store zu
eröffnen
in der historischen rheinländer menschen
meine frau und ich waren dort am
eröffnungstag um 14 uhr und der laden
war voll und ich sagte ralf wie geht es
dir
er sagte ich glaube es geht mir gut du
bist einzelhändler du kannst jetzt die
kasse klingeln lassen und der manager
sagte wir haben 41.000 eingenommen
fragte das gut und ich sagte das ist
sehr gut dann ging ich zurück in mein
büro und das telefon klingelte gegen
halb sechs und es war wie wir haben
hunderttausend dollar wie es das ich
sagte es ist großartig
er lernte einzelhändler zu sein
das hat der welt seine geschichte
erzählt jeder der nach new york kommt es
ist ja sogar im thorberg von new york
man versteht ralph lorenz botschafter
man dort durch geht schon wenn man an
diesen fenstern vorbei kommt als das
unternehmen weiter wuchs setzte loren
seiner mitarbeiter mehr denn je unter
druck
es gibt ein riesiges team von designern
und kreativen führungskräften sie
entwerfen machen alles aber bringen es
zur auf und rolf ist es der entscheidet
es gibt da diese erstaunlichen teile
kleine aufkleber die auf den tafeln
angebracht werden da steht drauf
und mit diesem akt im treff loren die
kleider die designs in besitz und
verdient die anerkennung
achtet mehr auf die details jeder andere
den ich in meinen getroffen habe und
wenn er entwirft ein sich die kleider
ansieht schau dahin und will ein reh wer
es noch viel spitze auf maler oder
plant es ist größer sein
1986 hatte das unternehmen einen
geschätzten wert von 600 millionen
dollar und laurin selbst war das
titelbild nicht seine modelle es schien
als könnte das leben für ihn nicht
besser werden als er seine nächste damen
kollektion heraus brachte aber hinter
den kulissen wurde der designer von
etwas alarmierendem erschüttert
wir waren
reif kam raus und ich sein gesicht wie
ich noch nie gesehen hatte ich sah dass
er mit den tränen kämpfte ich fing an zu
weinen
irgendetwas ging da vor sich ich wusste
nicht mal was es war es war einfach
nur die menschen die ihm am nächsten
standen wussten dass bei lauren ein
hirntumor festgestellt worden war
es war eines dieser dinge die man
einfach nicht glauben konnte die rave
nicht passieren konnten was bedeutet das
für die zukunft es gab damals so viele
fragen
[Musik]
als ich im taxi nach hause fuhren in den
nachrichten hörte dass der designerin
für eine gehirn operation eingeliefert
wurde
aber ja mein gott
natürlich habe ich mir sorgen gemacht er
tat mir so leid wissen sie
zum glück war der tumor gutartig
nach der operation lag ein langer weg
vor ihm und neue prioritäten
ich glaube nicht dass er sich sorgen
darüber gemacht hat was mit dem geschäft
passiert er hat sich sorgen um das leben
gemacht teilte sein martyrium mit
charlie watts
ich weiß noch als ich aus dem
krankenhaus kam und im central park
spazieren ging
ich war sehr schwach er sah ich ein paar
jungs den park rannten und schwitzten
und ich sagte zu mir das will ich auch
machen
einige wochen später kehrte loren zur
arbeit zurück ich glaube er kam sogar
aggressiver zurück als je zuvor aber ich
glaube er war ein bisschen entspannter
ein bisschen gelassener und schätzte
vielleicht jeden moment ein bisschen
mehr
er brachte eine kollektion für fitness
kleidung heraus und entwarf ein
umsatzstarkes ba vergab millionen aus um
diese produktlinien zu fördern james
fällen redakteur von women's wear daily
bezeichnet weil florian als ein
kraftpaket in der magazin welt weil er
einer der größten werbekunden ist wenn
ich mein parfüm auf den markt bringen
und eine anzeige geschaltet machen sie
ein profil von mir gucken sie sich mal
die anzahl der magazine an die ihn auf
das cover gesetzt haben pulse sein
40-jähriges jubiläum hatte das spiegelt
das ausmaß wieder in dem sie seine
finanzielle unterstützung der letzten
jahren zu schätzen wussten zu schätzen
wussten und auch darauf angewiesen waren
ein jährlicher werbeetat von 200
millionen dollar ist ein 800 pfund
schwerer gorilla ralph lauren sitzt wo
immer er will und wenn das das cover
ihres magazins ist dann wird ralf dort
sein
lorenz dominanz wurde auch deutlich als
audrey hepburn ihm den preis des
amerikanischen
modedesigner für sein lebenswerk
überreicht das war eine seiner mohsen
seiner ikone
die frau die als kleines kind in den
filmen gesehen hat bereich team jetzt
diese statue
erinnern sie sich an die prinzessin ich
habe sie mit der einführung von lorenz
lila label 1994 sei das unternehmen für
das ungeübte auge großartig aus
schließlich waren die umsätze so hoch
wie nie das war nur die halbe geschichte
lisa becker ist einzelhandels
journalisten
wie jeder einzelhändler der große träume
hat wuchs ist einfach zu schnell es
wurde viel kapital aufgewendet um die
marke dorthin zu bringen wo er sie haben
wollte das in verbindung mit einem sehr
glanzlosen vertrieb schuf den perfekten
sturm für ein unternehmen das fast am
rande des bankrotts stand
lauren brauchte einen rettungsanker und
fand ihn bei goldman sachs die
investment firma kaufte 28 prozent von
polo ralph lauren für 135 millionen
dollar es war für uns überraschend weil
wir nicht wussten dass er finanziell so
weit mit dem rücken zur wand stand und
ich glaube das hat zu der goldman sachs
investition geführt
sie sind sehr gut darin herauszufinden
welche unternehmen langfristiges
wachstum versprechen und genau das haben
sie bei ralph lauren gesehen die
finanzspritze führte zu einem
exponentiellen wachstum und polo ralph
lauren eröffnete neue läden und
renovierte ältere
1997 war ralph lauren der
meistverkauften designer der welt die
verbraucher gaben fast 5 milliarden
dollar pro jahr für seine produkte aus
goldman sachs sei noch größeres
potenzial und drängte ihn zum börsengang
doch er war nicht so sicher
er hatte immer bedenken dass er in eine
aktiengesellschaft weniger
handlungsfreiheit haben würde das ist
nicht mehr seine eigene marke war weil
er mit aktionären und einem vorstand zu
tun hatte
[Musik]
trotz seiner anfänglichen vorbehalte
beschloss ralph lauren im juni 97 sein
unternehmen an die börse zu bringen
liszt daran einzelhandels analysten bei
macquarie capital
es beobachtet das unternehmen seit ja
eine herausforderung bei einem
börsengang besteht darin dass die
investoren von quartal zu quartal von
jahr zu jahr ein sehr gleichmäßiges
wachstum sehen wollen und ich glaube
dass sie in den ersten tagen als
aktiengesellschaft damit zu kämpfen
hatten nach dem börsengang berichteten
wir über seine jahresversammlung in der
stand vor den aktionären und sagt er die
wallstreet versteht mich nicht unsere
anteilseigner sitzen nur da ich wünschte
sie würden verstehen was wir tun
laurin versuchte nun die aktionäre
zufrieden zu stellen er verkaufte in
mehr leben aber das umsatzwachstum
verlangsamte sich und die gewinnmargen
gingen zurück er 16 monate nach dem
höchststand von 33 dollar pro aktie fiel
sie unter 17 dollar
ich weiß dass es ihm gequält hat wir
haben darüber gesprochen er war
frustriert dass die wall street nicht
das sehen konnte was ihm völlig klar war
und seit 1967 immer klar gewesen war
dass er es war dass er der mann war es
trieb ihn in den wahnsinn und in dieses
umfeld kam ein mann namens roger forrer
der einer der großen einzelhandels
manager amerikas war roger fahrer kam
und restrukturierte die und sexy teile
des geschäfts lieferkette betrieb und
was er auch tat erkaufte die lizenzen
zurück er brachte diese marke zurück ins
haus und stellte sicher dass all diese
marken unter dem dach von ran
sie machten gerade eine enorme
wachstumsphase durch
zusammenstellen das die botschaft
gab ein marken video in auftrag das mich
inspiriert das ist eine geschichte oder
ein thema das mich anspricht bei mir
besteht eine koalition nicht auf seinem
ärmel oder einen bestimmten stoff ich
entwerfe sie aus einem traum bach aus
kontrolle ist für ihn sehr wichtig und
auf diese weise konnten wir eine
einheitliche botschaft präsentieren er
musste nicht dabei sein aber es war als
wäre er dabei gewesen
expandierte wanka mit blick auf den
internationalen absatz eröffnete er
flagship stores in mailand tokio und
sogar moskau
amerika wird in frankreich von
mcdonald's und ralph lauren
repräsentiert und ich meine was von
beidem lässt unsere kultur besser
aussehen ich glaube der ralph lauren
store ist so eine art symbolische
amerikanische botschaft aber im sommer
2012 wurde der designer angegriffen als
enthüllt wurde dass die von lauren
entworfenen olympia trikots nicht in den
usa hergestellt wurden made in china das
ist china china sie sollten alle
uniformen nehmen und schob rennen das
unternehmen versprach die trikots für
die winterspiele 2014 in den usa zu
produzieren
während seiner gesamten karriere
kultivierte ralph lauren sein eigenes
image der sorgt er hat wohnsitze auf der
fifth avenue in jamaica long island und
bedford new york und eine 17.000 hektar
ranch in colorado wo er zeit mit seiner
frau und seinen drei erwachsenen kindern
verbringen und er gibt viel zeit und
geld für eine ganz andere leidenschaft
aus gols autos sind spaß und spiel
zeigen und sie bieten dir eine ganz
andere erfahrung für mich arbeiten sie
sehr hart dieses werbevideo auf dem jahr
2010 kündigte eine pariser ausstellung
einiger seiner über 60 oldtimer an
er hat mir mal gesagt er sammelt vor
allem deshalb autos weil er sie einfach
liebt und sie zu ihm passen er sammelt
keine kunst im gegensatz zu den meisten
menschen in seiner einkommensklasse er
sagte man kann ein gemälde nicht fahren
und er liebt es eines seiner autos
zunehmen und damit an einem
sonntagnachmittag herumzufahren
paul goldberger sagt dass lohan bei
einigen seiner autos die farbe ändert
er sieht sich etwas an und sagt das ist
wunderbar und aufregend und schön aber
es könnte noch schöner sein und ich
möchte es noch perfekter machen
seit 40 jahren ralph lauren mit seinem
streben nach perfektion das unternehmen
das seinen namen trägt als ceo und
vorstandsvorsitzender fest im griff
ich glaube das symbol mit dem polo pony
hat bestand es ist etwas das die kunden
über einen langen zeitraum gewählt haben
es ist wahrscheinlich die beste
geschichte in meiner berichterstattung
weil es so viele wachstumsmöglichkeiten
gibt mit denen sich der umsatz in den
nächsten jahren wohl mehr als verdoppeln
wird
der ehemalige krawatten verkäufer ist
mit 72 jahren einer der reichsten
menschen der welt und siebeneinhalb
milliarden dollar schwer ich glaube dass
das letzte stückchen ralf litz dass in
ihm geblieben ist ein kern von
unsicherheit ist und das ist der
treibstoff der den motor antreibt der
die person antreibt die diese marke
verkörpert
ralf roth sich nicht eine minute lang
auf seinen lorbeeren aus ich meine man
kann den moment genießen aber man muss
verstehen dass man die dinge am laufen
halten muss man darf keine one trick
pony sein apropos nie